[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon good afternoon it's cold
innit on behalf of President Charles M
vest and the dr. Martin Luther King
Planning Committee distinguished guests
faculty and students ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 20th annual
celebration at MIT of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. my name is Andrew Humphrey and
I'm a second year graduate student for
PhD in atmospheric science the theme for
this year's celebration is the movement
for economic and social justice 1994 and
Beyond a theme like this may imply that
like in 1964 or in 1694 there is no
economic or social justice today in
order for us to move beyond 1994 we must
look behind 1994 at the struggles and
battles our people had to endure to
bring us up to where we are today
one thing is clear during dr. King's
time all time and energy was spent being
alert responsive and persistent for the
economic and social welfare and
eventually human rights of all people
today we must have that same energy and
vigilance because ironically the
problems and language of those times 30
or 40 years ago are creeping back or
have never left us two legacies of dr.
King were voting rights and voter
education because voting is part of
being a full participant in this society
and demanding positive social and
economic change and dr. King once wrote
justice delayed is justice denied after
a delay of over 30 years in Mississippi
justice has finally come on the
assassination of Medgar Evers
who is another champion of economic and
social rights the assassin Byron de la
Beckwith has been put away for life the
widow myrlie Evers said while gaining
her composure I think it has been a very
very long battle well it has been for
her and it still is for us today as we
move beyond 1994 at this time we should
applaud those persons who for twenty
years have been influential and ret in
the recognition of dr. King's birthday
and producing this King celebration for
you from MIT the Associate Dean of the
Graduate School dr. Isaac Kolbert the
director of program advancement
professor Royce Flippen associate
director of the financial aid department
miss Yvonne Gittens chairman of the
corporation dr. Paul E gray who was also
instrumental in bringing mrs. King here
to us today professor of athletics dr.
Leo Osgood MIT episcopal chaplain
Reverend Scott paradise assistant dean
to the Graduate School mrs. margaret
daniel tyler and special assistant to
the president dr. Clarence G Williams
also from the Cambridge community we
have the director of the educational
Talent Search program mr. ron Critchlow
and those who have retired professor
Frank Jones and Professor Robert Mann
now over 20 years there are several
other persons on this list however for
the sake of time we would like to thank
all of these people at this time as a
whole for making this event a success
Reverend Scott paradise will now open
our celebration with the invocation
let us pray O God of love and justice we
come together in a spirit of gratitude
we remember with thanks the life and
work of Martin Luther King jr. we give
thanks for the courage with which he
challenged the perpetrators of racial
oppression in spite of threats against
his life in welfare we give thanks for
their persistence with which he taught
love and nonviolent action as the means
to change an evil system we give thanks
for the stubbornness of which he
supported the victims of economic
injustice even when he knew this would
not make him popular we give thanks for
the truth he spoke against the war in
Vietnam in spite of warnings that such
words of truth would cost him major
support we give thanks for the deeds of
love and self sacrifice and heroism that
his voice inspired among so many we give
thanks for his vision of American
society as it ought to be as it might be
and as God willing as it will be we pray
that in this time together our our
determination will be stoked to continue
the work that Martin Luther King jr.
left yet unfinished amen
thank you very much Reverend paradise
for those very timely inaccurate words
now will everyone please join in singing
the first stanza of lift every voice and
sing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you we were led by the pianist
John Ross now we'll hear from our new
generation with some fresh perspectives
on dr. King we will hear first from an
MIT Upward Bound program student mr.
Joshua monto then from mi t--'s
undergraduate school we have miss
LaShawn Berrien and finally from mi
t--'s graduate school we have mr. Joshua
Joseph Junior
president vests keynote speaker mrs.
King program presenters and guests good
afternoon
when it was brought to me to come speak
here today the name Martin Luther King
came up in the conversation of course
and I went through my mind and I was
trying to think of all the things that I
knew about him all I can come up with
the only things like it came up with was
that he was a civil rights leader the
march on Washington and that he was
assassinated and I feel that my
generation really doesn't know how much
that he's benefited us and I think that
and a much greater emphasis you put on
Martin Luther King and that a lot of
people my age you know a lot more about
him
because looking through his works he
said lots of great things that are even
relevant twists in 1994
news flash gunman opened fire - a vous
skating rink seven youth injured today
part of our theme adjusted social
justice so as I looked through dr.
King's work I ran across the eulogy of
martyred children that was written in
1963 31 years ago as I read a part of it
touched me and Arendt like this so in
spite of the darkness of this hour we
must not despair we must not become
bitter enormous we aren't Harbor the
desire to retaliate with violence we
must not lose faith in our white
brothers somehow we must believe that
the most misguided among them can learn
to respect the dignity and the worth of
all human personality after reading this
work I wondered if dr. King was alive
today and reading you g to deal with the
aftermath of today's street drama for
all you generation gap folks that means
street violence
what would he write news flash black
police officer shot and killed suspect
18 year old black teen have the times
changed drastically and dr. King's day
was easier to recognize the enemy
bigots racists and all those who were
violently against the uplifting of
African Americans the majority was white
so the enemy was easy to identify unity
amongst blacks at the same time was so
strong it brought tears to your eyes
singing living fighting and dying for
the struggle but today things have
changed instead of singing and living
we're fighting and dying in large
numbers newsflash 12 year-old Tiffany
Moore an innocent bystander was shot and
killed by a ricocheting bullet see you
tomorrow
it's something that is not easily said
between inner-city youth to see another
day has become a sort of gift or
challenge nowadays we have had to come
with grips were making goodbyes a lot
more final as we part and go our
separate ways we pray in hope that we
will see that friend again and I
emphasize hope for Hope is all we have
left to say that is not truth to lie to
yourself I'm only 17 years old but I bet
that I've seen more violence than most
of you in this audience to get home each
day and see my mother is a blessing
because I know that many mothers would
never had the chance to see their
children ever again is this the fate of
the human race at this stage we were
praying just to see another day will it
come to the point that we're praying
this to see the next hour a minute a lot
of folks want to focus on the dream well
it seems to me the dream is quickly
becoming their chapter and a Stephen
King novel a nightmare but what is our
destiny I have no problem with dreaming
but my president forces me to focus on
reality so what if we bring the eulogy
in 1994 eyes with dr. King right in
spite of darkness of this hour we must
not despair we must not become bitter
Norma's real hardware the desire to
retaliate with violence we may not lose
faith in ourselves somehow we must
believe that the most misguiding among
us will learn to respect the dignity and
the worth of all human personality I
think you would thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon when I was asked to
reflect today on what dr. Martin Luther
King Junior's legacy means to me to mrs.
Coretta Scott King and all of you I was
a little afraid that I would not be able
to find the words that would adequately
express what dr. King's legacy means to
me
but then it occurred to me that I really
didn't need the words at all but that
who and what I am are evidence enough I
am a young black female engineer at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
it is because of dr. King's dream that I
can say these words all too often in
society we applaud a person's
achievements when we feel that they have
been successful and we tell them that we
we encourage them to be to work harder
if we feel that they haven't lived up to
their full potential
what is overlooked in this as a person's
ability to perceive achievement dr.
Martin Luther King jr. did not ignore
this crucial element in the advancement
of african-american people
it was dr. King's belief that every
child in America should be entitled to
equal education and opportunity in order
to pursue their dreams and aspirations
through this dream dr. King opened up a
whole world for little black children to
not only dream of achievement but to
accept the reality that they can succeed
at anything of which they can dream this
is a greatest gift that dr. King has
given my generation and as a young black
woman I stand in this institution and I
know that I can and will accomplish
anything which I set out to do and I
realized that this knowledge is a gift
given to me and the legacy of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. and I would like to say
to mrs. Coretta Scott King that it is an
honor for me to tell you that your
husband has played an integral role in
me being able to stand in this
institution and I can only imagine what
an honor it was to know him as a person
but each day that I achieve and I get
one step closer to my own dreams I know
what an honor it is to benefit from his
legacy from who he was from all that he
has done and from all that he continues
to do through the dreams of young black
children in America
[Applause]
imagine if you will if the third Monday
of every January were not the first
national holiday honoring a black man
perhaps if all were perfect or even just
significantly not as bad as they once
were seemed to be and appear to remain
perhaps we would not be honoring dr.
King at all at least not for leading
through nonviolent civil disobedience
the fight for dignity justice and humane
misfortune what it would have been like
not to have had dr. King and the
struggle for I do not know what it is to
not be in the midst of struggle today I
loved one struggle in Opelousas
Louisiana flew to another here in
Cambridge and indeed live and exist in
another here at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology good afternoon
in humble privilege through joyful
reserved with deep adoration and
significant things I offer reflections
on the life and legacy of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. born in December of 1969
I missed the life but thank God I got
the legacy that remains grateful I am
that the dream of yesterday remains a
vision for me today and hope for all
tomorrow my role is to become a
perpetuator of the dream so that my life
and my spirit the life and the spirit of
all of us will exploit that which is
good right and just in shaping our
political socio-economic framework
deeply rooted in a moral and religious
conviction to build a better country and
to become a better world I am thankful
to dr. King for building a bridge for me
that links my present to an
older past it was almost a century
before dr. King was born that Negros
attacked the Jim Crow ism of this
country through the speaking of Charles
Lennox Riemann and I quote there is a
distinction between social and civil
rights we all claim the privilege of
selecting our society in associations
but in civil rights one man has not the
prerogative to define rights for another
in quote to reflect on dr. King is to
remember the past not to be doomed by it
or to condemn others because of it
but to live grow and Excel in spite of
it dr. King I thank you for building
that bridge in spite of my regret for
the need of its very existence I reflect
of a parallel journey and it encourages
me dr. King born and raised in the south
myself born and raised in the South dr.
King a graduate of Morehouse College a
historically black college myself a
graduate of Southern University a
historically black University dr. King
choosing to be a servant of all in
association with Alpha Phi Alpha myself
choosing to exemplify the cardinal
principles of manhood scholarship
perseverance and uplift with the
Brotherhood of Omega sci-fi fraternity
incorporated and both choosing New
England to broaden horizons in education
and the human experience all of us must
step onto that bridge which leads
through education for without education
we are destined to fail but as cottagey
Woodson mentions in the mis-education of
the negro I quote the same process the
same educational process which inspires
and stimulus stimulates the oppressor
with the thought that he is everything
and has accomplished everything
worthwhile depresses and crushes at the
same time the spark of genius in the
Negro by making him feel that his race
does not amount to much and never will
measure up to the standards of other
people's dr. King's legacy
begs us to prevent the system of
oppression from handicapping our hearts
minds and souls it is not enough to
matriculate at MIT and escape into the
protection of science and engineering
agendas we must give back to the
communities built upon the blood sweat
and tears of our mothers and fathers of
Africa our agenda our our agenda is
multi objective and we cannot cross that
bridge without first building community
I commend the spirit of chocolate City
in choosing to demonstrate last year in
a non-violent manner
it was dr. King while in a Birmingham
Alabama jail cell defended his mission
against the attacks of prominent white
clergymen he said actually we who engage
in nonviolent direct action are not the
creators of tension we merely bring to
surface the hidden tension that is
already alive we bring it out in the
open where it can be seen and dealt with
like a ball that can never be cured as
long as it is covered up but must be
open with all its pus flowing ugliness
to the natural medicine of air and light
and justice might likewise be exposed
with all of attention AIDS exposing
creates to the light of human conscious
and the air of national opinion before
it became be cured I close by saying a
special thank you to Dean Isaac Hobart
for allowing that caged bird to sing in
a strange and distant land I close with
W aid rumbles the bridge builder' in the
spirit that dr. Martin Luther King jr.
built a bridge
for our struggles today an old man going
alone highway came at the evening cold
and gray to a chasm vast and wide and
steep with waters rolling code in deep
the old man crossed in the Twilight dim
the sullen stream hell no fears for him
and he stopped when safe on the other
side to build a bridge to span the tide
oh man said a fellow pilgrim
you're wasting your strength with
building here your journey will end with
the ending day you never again will pass
this way you've crossed the chasm deep
and wide why build you this bridge at
Eventide the builder lifted his old gray
head good friend in the path I have come
he said there followed after me today a
youth whose feet must pass this way the
chasm that was us not to me to that
fair-haired youth may pitfall be he to
must cross in a twilight dim a good
friend I am building this bridge for him
thank you
Thank You Joshua Thank You LaShawn and
Thank You Joshua very strong very
powerful messages very good we will have
a musical selection from our member of
from a member of our own community here
miss Pamela ambushed is from the
Department of music and theater arts she
will be singing the song dreams and she
will she will be accompanied by pianist
John Ross thank you the note of
encouragement is dream on
[Music]
when Martin was a little boy he was
driven by his dreams God spoke to him
told him that he had chosen him when
others didn't understand Martin still
believed
aimed and trusted God trusted and was
willing to dream
when the word just did believe God had
passed
[Music]
Oh
follow hope wherever God leads in the
seed of dreams
[Music]
there's not a fairly deep enough God
can't guide us through he walk with us
walk the roughest Road so hard
[Music]
and stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much miss Pamela ambush
and thank you again mr. John Ross
beautiful now we will listen to remarks
from President Charles M vest who will
introduce our keynote speaker mrs.
Coretta Scott King
[Applause]
colleagues and friends good afternoon it
is truly a great honor to have with us
today mrs. Coretta Scott King on this
the 20th anniversary of mi t--'s annual
celebration of the birth of Martin
Luther King jr. we all value very deeply
this powerful presence among us today in
fact it seems particularly appropriate
for mrs. King to be here this year just
a month after some 2000 African American
women came together at MIT for three-day
conference
for a three-day conference entitled
black women and the Academy defending
our name as the first major gathering of
its kind this conference far exceeded
the expectations of its organizers two
remarkable young faculty members here at
MIT professors Evelyn Hammond and Robin
Kilson this conference served as a
beacon of hope as it created in those
few days a community of scholars who
will now be able to draw on and
reinforce each other's strengths and
there is no question that the conference
served as a challenge to all of us in
higher education to increase the number
of our black faculty members both men
and women and to recognize and deal with
the issues of race in our scholarly
lives and in our communities at MIT the
challenge is clear we can now see the
changing face of America mirrored in our
undergraduate students it is not a
perfect reflection to be sure but we are
moving in the right direction the mirror
begins to cloud however when it comes to
our graduate students and to our staff
and the faculty and the glass is frankly
distorted when it comes to our faculty
and administration we at MIT respond to
change by generating or incorporating
new ideas and new knowledge and our
professional and scholarly lives if we
are to maintain our high quality and our
relevance to the world we now must
become equally adept at incorporating
cultural and demographic change into our
life as an academic community to do this
we must recognize and draw together the
full range of talents of the men and
women from all racial cultural economic
and ethnic backgrounds that comprise our
community and we must continue to enrich
the fabric of our institution this
requires first that we take renewed and
affirmative action to ensure equality of
opportunity and education and employment
at the Institute three years ago we
started a program to do
this in the domain of faculty
recruitment we are beginning to see
results over this period we have
successfully recruited recruited eleven
men and women of color to the faculty
that may not sound like much but it is
progress bringing more people of color
to our campus as faculty as staff as
well as the students is just the first
step however real success will be
achieved through serious attention to
mentoring and to career development at
all levels and for that to succeed it is
imperative that we work to create at MIT
an atmosphere of civility collegiality
and mutual respect one that stimulates
and supports all of our students staff
and faculty there are many on campus who
will tell you that the environment here
does not do that and the diversity of
race and class and culture has
fragmented our community there is some
truth to that but I must believe that we
can do something about it and that
indeed we must to this end I'm
appointing this morning a Presidential
Committee on campus race relations it is
a diverse group of thirteen students
staff faculty and administrators that
will be chaired by associate provost
Ellen Harris it will catalyze activities
enhance communication and networking and
administer a modest grants program to
support innovative ideas arising from
the community on ways too far to to
further harmonious race relations this
idea grew out of a quite wonderful
grassroots group that began meeting
during the last year on an ad-hoc basis
and I'm very grateful to them for
catalyzing this one of the things that
we can do to create a climate of greater
mutual respect on our campus is to honor
those who have honored us by their
achievements in this regard I am also
pleased today to announce the
establishment of a new endowed
professorial chair at MIT to be known as
the
Robert our tailor professorship
this faculty chair will honor in
perpetuity the memory of an illustrious
alumnus our first african-american
graduate one century ago the
distinguished architect went on to
accomplish many things including the
design of much of the campus of Tuskegee
Institute this professorship will stand
as both a reminder and as an instrument
of mi t--'s commitment to diversity
it will provide yet another way for the
Institute and for a distinguished
faculty member through his or her
scholarship and professional activities
in any of our schools to contribute to
the enhancement of our institutional
excellence and to the advancement of
diversity on the campus we will have
this endowed chair firmly in place
during the coming year these are just a
few small steps that we are taking to
make MIT a place where everyone reaches
his or her potential for achievement for
contribution and for fulfillment success
in these efforts will enable us not only
to reflect better the changing face of
America but to draw on the full range of
talents that are needed to meet the
challenges of a changing world I believe
that we are making some progress and I
think it is fair to say that the modest
gains that have been made here in the
Academy and elsewhere can trace their
roots to the courageous advocacy of
civil rights leaders such as dr. King
and of Coretta Scott King such battles
have been won but much remains to be
done it still comes as something of a
shock to me to realize that virtually
all of the students here today had not
been born when dr. King was leading the
crusade for racial harmony and social
justice through non-violent action for
them as indeed their voices have told us
today is a figure from history rather
than from personal memory to be sure we
need to be inspired by and understand
the lessons of history if we are to make
progress toward
a society that truly embraces people
different races cultures and classes but
we also need articulate effective and
resolute guides in the here and now to
help us along the way we are fortunate
indeed that mrs. King is just such a
leader Coretta Scott King was born and
raised in Alabama she earned an A B from
Antioch College in 1951 her bachelor's
degree in music from the New England
Conservatory in 1954 while at the
conservatory
another voice student introduced her to
Martin Luther King jr. who was studying
for his doctorate in theology at Boston
University they were married in 1953 and
after completing their degrees they
chose to accept the pastored of the
Dexter Avenue Baptist Church in
Montgomery Alabama during the 1950s and
60s mrs. King shared and carried her
husband's advocacy of peace and justice
across the nation and throughout the
world a tireless speaker and organizer
an accomplished singer and teacher she
dedicated an extraordinary amount of
energy and vision to the cause of civil
rights all while raising four children
in the days and weeks after the
assassination of dr. King in April of
1968 she calmed the anger and despair of
his followers she gave the nation a
model of dignity and caring in the midst
of grief and she became both a leader
the symbol of the movement for peace and
justice she has traveled the world in
this cause as a goodwill ambassador
political activists journalists
television commentator most importantly
was the founder and chief executive
officer of the Martin Luther King jr.
Center for nonviolent social change the
center which is located near the
Ebenezer Baptist Church in Atlanta now
covers three full blocks the
neighborhood that has been declared a
national historic site the center
as offices dr. King's tomb his birth
home the King Library and Archives a
cultural center a chapel and conference
and meeting facilities last year it
attracted more than three million
visitors the center offers programs for
young people teachers community leaders
and others on such issues as voter
education and registration literacy the
Performing Arts early childhood
education conflict resolution nonviolent
protest strategies and job training just
to name a few the center with her
leadership has been a pivotal force in
building major interracial coalition's
that serve the cause of social economic
and political justice ladies and
gentlemen it is a deep honor and
privilege to present to you mrs. Coretta
Scott King
[Applause]
thank you very much president vest for
your very kind and generous introduction
and let me thank all of you were you
very warm welcome and it's a great
privilege for me to be here today to
participate in this Martin Luther King
celebration it only took me 20 years to
get here
but I am here and I'm very proud to be
here
I was telling professor Osgood that and
and president vest that I couldn't come
during the time that we are celebrating
in Atlanta because we have a nine a ten
day celebration and it's not possible
for me to come so I think after you
decided to allow me to come after the
birthday and holiday then I could make
it so thank you for giving me that
consideration I want to congratulate
Martin Luther King jr. Day planning
committee for the work that you have
done over these 20 years and for this
particular program this anniversary and
certainly to thank you for inviting me
you have chosen well in making your
theme for this program the movement for
economic and social justice
1994 and beyond I feel this way because
I believe that the best way to celebrate
and commemorate Martin Luther King Jr's
birthday is to recommit ourselves to his
unfinished work for social and economic
justice most people are aware that the
civil rights movement focused on the
elimination of racial segregation but we
were also concerned about economic
empowerment of the disadvantaged and
impoverished people and our communities
my husband once said that the
inseparable twin of racial injustice is
economic injustice in other words
wherever you find racism you will also
find economic injustice Martin
understood that civil rights meant
little without economic resources what
is the right to sit at an integrated
lunch counter he once asked if you can't
afford the price of a meal the struggle
for economic empowerment was an integral
part of every campaign of the civil
rights movement from Montgomery to
Memphis
we always press for a greater share of
jobs employment training and economic
opportunities even as we struggled
against racial discrimination and let us
never forget that Martin Luther King jr.
was assassinated and a labor union
organizing campaign he felt strongly
that trade unions were essential for the
economic empowerment of all Americans
and black Americans in particular as he
said our needs are identical with
Labor's needs decent wages fair working
conditions livable housing old age
security health and welfare measures
conditions in which families can grow
have education for their children and
respect in the community
end of quote he went to Memphis as a
part of the Poor People's Campaign which
was an interracial coalition Martin
organized to press for fundamental
reforms to eliminate the cancer of
poverty from American life
Martin understood that there were more
white people than black people living in
poverty he felt that a social justice
movement had an obligation to help white
people Hispanic Native American and
other ethnic groups who were suffering
the ravages of poverty as well as black
Americans and even today more than 25
years after Martin was assassinated in
Memphis economic empowerment is still
the central issue we face we certainly
have our work cut out for us in meeting
this challenge our challenge is now to
organize a nationwide multiracial
coalition for job training employment
and education program
in our communities we're not just
talking about summer jobs we want stable
jobs at a living wage so people can
raise their families at decent living
standards we need tax incentives to make
investment in poor communities
attractive to business investors just as
we need tax disincentives for
corporations that invest in other
nations instead of our cities we have to
be about the business of
self-empowerment we have to be about the
business of self-empowerment as well
this means we have to organize
cooperative enterprises so unemployed
people will not only have a decent job
but a share in the ownership of the
enterprise that employs them and the
same thing goes for housing ownership
ownership is the key to economic
revitalization having a stake in the
ownership of our homes and places of
employment is the beginning of political
social and economic empowerment as
Andrew Young has said the struggle of
the 90s is to integrate the money
[Applause]
since it was founded in 1968 the King
Center has been active in the struggle
for economic empowerment for minorities
and working people the center played a
major role in organizing the national
committee for full employment which was
instrumental in passing the
humphrey-hawkins Act and other
legislations to provide jobs that was
way back in 1978 some of you would
remember it many of you would not
remember it in this audience but I hope
somebody remembered that we did get a
bill but it wasn't it wasn't enforced
and it didn't get implemented and it was
watered down but I'm not discouraged we
have to keep working for full employment
legislation I really believe that it's
going to be the key we have lobbied long
hours for employment bills and we have
aggressively tapped public and private
sector initiatives to fund job training
and employment programs for at-risk
young people the center has also
supported needed increases in the
minimum wage labor union organizing
campaigns tax reforms to benefit poor
people financial aid for education for
needy families and a host of legislative
reforms for economic empowerment we have
a great opportunity to advance the cause
of economic empowerment for working
people and the poor in this election
year we have to take control of our own
destiny by launching a nationwide voter
education Drive followed by the most
aggressive aggressive voter turnout
campaign in history it just so happens
that in a democracy if you don't get
registered and vote then you have no
political power and therefore you cannot
complain about what policies that the
legislative body has passed because you
didn't have a part in making and
participating in that through your
elected representative and it's very
important that students understand the
power that they have and organize
themselves and get registered and vote
in every single election and I know some
of you say we don't have anything to
vote for you always have something
vote for and I challenge you on that and
remember that political commitment
doesn't stop at the ballot box after the
elections are over we have to do a
better job of staying on our elected
officials we have to write them more
often we have to become better informed
about legislation for economic
empowerment we have to meet with them
until they are so tired of us that they
begin to listen and respond to our
concerns believe me it works
my most fervent hope is that the night
that 1994 will be the year of the
political system that the political
system begins to respond to the need for
a genuine economic opportunity for
Americans of all races above all let us
keep faith that we can do it with enough
creativity and determination we will be
able to create a society where every
child can have a decent education and a
chance for a better life and where every
parent can have a stable job that will
enable them to support their families
let us embrace this common vision and
mobilize all of our resources to bring
it into being let us put hope and
economic opportunity for all Americans
black white red brown and yellow at the
very top of the political agenda now we
have witnessed some very impressive
civil rights progress throughout
American history throughout American
society since Martin Luther King jr.
began to lead the civil rights movement
no it's difficult for younger people to
appreciate and understand this and I I
do sympathise with you but as the young
man said our first speaker we have to
learn about and study about what the
past history has been it is important
that we know what the progress has that
has been made is about and how it came
about and the fact that many people
suffered and even died that we might
have the rights that we have today and
it is also important that if you're
going to be intelligent an intelligent
voter you're going to have to know the
issues and that's why it's important to
study your history and American history
includes the history of black people
which is not properly been written
and commemorating Martin to King
Junior's birthday I realized that it was
important that America take the Martin
Luther King philosophy and it's and his
methods of non-violent social change
embrace that philosophy and so that
philosophy begins to permeate our
society so that we could have a
revolution of values which he called for
and the only way to do that really not
the only way but one of the best ways I
think of doing that was to have a
holiday in his memory not for his sake
but because America needs it our world
needs it and I will speak more about
those values we have one the movement
mourn many great victories including the
desegregation of public facilities and
legislated guarantees of voting rights
yet racism remains perhaps the single
most destructive force in American
society a whole range of social problems
including poverty urban decay crime the
failure of our schools and violence all
a grated by the persistence of racism
until America comes to grips with the
problem of racism we will not be able to
create the great democracy of Martin
Luther King Junior's dream racism not
only hurts African Americans it not only
hurts Hispanic Asian and Native
Americans it hurts
white people racism divides people of
all races who would otherwise share
common interests racism creates a gulf
of fear and suspicion between
communities communities in every city it
feeds the cycle of poverty crime and
violence that is turning many of the
nation's urban centers into ghost towns
it prevents our public schools from
fulfilling their potential and it
undermines the credibility of us moral
leadership equal
Namah copper tunity in particular has
remained an elusive goal the average
medium income for african-american
families is still less than 60 percent
of the figure for white families
nearly half of African American children
are still living in poverty the
unemployment rate for black workers
today is about double the rate for white
workers my husband was irrevocably
committed to diversity in all
institutions of society including the
executive suites of America's great
corporations and universities when I
speak of integration he once said I
don't mean a romantic mixing of colors I
mean a real sharing of power and
responsibility
there has been little progress for
african-american executives in the
highest echelons of corporate management
today only one black American heads a
fortune 500 company and we are
underrepresented in the middle and upper
decision-making levels of all but a very
few multinational corporations women and
minorities still encounter the glass
ceiling when they try to move up the
corporate ladder or in the academic
sector it is so important for companies
and institutions of higher education to
make an earnest commitment to go beyond
the letter of the law and to make
diversity not just a buzzword for the
public relations programs but a real
policy that will be reflected at every
level of corporate decision-making now I
heard president vest speak about the
innovations that you have just you just
going into here at this great University
and I want to commend you for what you
are doing and what you're going to do
more in the future
and certainly as you so well said you've
not done enough
and you certainly are not alone in that
that speaks for most of the institutions
of higher learning in our country but I
am encouraged that you are aware of it
and that you're doing something about it
now that you are doing something about
it I'm going to charge you a little bit
MIT can become a national leader in
promoting diversity by setting up more
scholarships for minorities by reaching
out to help needy young people to get a
decent education
I know you're doing some of this but I
said more and providing more tenured
professorship and high administrative
positions
and this will not only benefit
minorities and women
it will also benefit white students and
the entire university community by
helping to prepare them for living in a
multicultural society
[Applause]
a commitment to improving race relations
can help prevent further racial conflict
and I'm glad that you've set up this
committee and I'd like to get a report
on it by this time next year
if we can build such bridges of
knowledge and understanding between
people of all races and religions we
will sow the seeds of a new unity in
America I'd like to speak about
religious diversity because I think any
of us who claim to be the followers of
Martin Luther King jr. he was a
Christian clergyman first of all he was
a minister of the gospel as he would say
and he took his calling very seriously
if we are as followers we have a moral
obligation to deplore the recent
expressions of anti-semitism that have
polluted our society
anti-semitism is as reprehensible and
contemptible as racism and anyone who
supports this form of bigotry does a
disservice to their country as my
husband said in a speech he gave just a
month before his assassination and I
quote for the black man to be struggling
for justice and then turn around and be
anti-semitic is not only a very
irrational course it is a very immoral
course and where ever we have seen
anti-semitic Semitism we have condemned
it with all of our might end of quote
he saw America not as a melting pot but
as a vibrant vibrant mosaic of people of
all races religions and ethnic groups
we need not surrender our group
identities he felt instead we can weave
them into a cooperative and mutually
supportive framework he understood that
multicultural unity was not only a way
we can live together but also a very
powerful tool for personal social
economic and political empowerment he
understood that equal rights can be
legislated to a great extent but genuine
Brotherhood and sisterhood cannot for it
comes from the heart
we have learned that there's nothing
automatic about good race relations
instead we must consciously work to
build interracial trust and cooperation
if we are serious about fulfilling
Martin Luther King Junior's dream of a
nation United in justice and peace
somehow someway we have to find a way to
live together as Martin said like life
racial understanding is not something
that we find but something that we must
create the ability to work together to
understand each other will not be found
ready-made it must be created by the
fact of contact in the quote such a
commitment can help prevent further
racial conflict if we can build such
bridges of knowledge and understanding
between people of all races and
religions we will sow the seeds of a
unity in America during the civil rights
movement it was college students like
you students of all races and religions
who provided crucial leadership for
social change young people like you are
always the vanguard of any social
movement setting an energetic tone of
courage and commitment which compels an
aggressive spirit of social change never
doubt that you have the power to provide
leadership for social change
college students provided decisive
leadership for ending the Vietnam War
and college students were in the
Birmingham and Montgomery and Selma and
all of the campaigns of the civil rights
movement and now we need you to once
again lead us to a higher and more noble
destiny so I want to appeal to you today
to rise up and lead a new revolution of
social change and I say that knowing
knowing that as scientists and engineers
that not many of you go and do that but
I want to challenge you anyway but as
you go about doing what you must do do
it as Martin Luther King said in an
extraordinary way and do it with heart
and soul and do it as a service to your
fellow human beings to your community to
your nation and to the world
because we do live in a global community
I appeal to you to reject the easy road
of apathy and indifference reject
materialism and drug abuse and all of
the other selfish concerns and leads
your generation to a better America
where every person can lead a decent
life in peace and harmony and with
justice for all we must take a more
proactive approach to challenging racism
through intensive workshops and the King
Center in Atlanta which I serve as
president and chief executive officer
has also trained thousands of people
from all walks of life including
teachers and students and young people
and at-risk young people at that in
applying dr. King's teachings to
eliminate poverty and racism and all
forms of violence Americans of all races
must now begin to work together with the
faith that we are all brothers and
sisters and the great human family the
King Center in Atlanta is making a
contribution to this effort by educating
and training people of every age group
about the values of love and compassion
and the methods of non-violent conflict
resolution and Reconciliation that
empower dr. King in his leadership of
the civil rights movement we feel
strongly that this training is urgently
needed to address the crises of violence
that is destroying the hopes of
America's young people of all races
alcohol and drug abuse handguns
unemployment disintegrating families and
adequate educational opportunities and
media glorification of violence all
contribute to pervasive alienation
despair and hopelessness among young
people all of these problems are
interconnected all reinforce each other
to create a destructive mix of
conditions that make frustration anger
and violence among young people all but
inevitable we have to keep working for a
more just society but we can't afford to
wait for the day when it finally becomes
a reality because we are losing too many
young people to the war
in our streets and at the King Center in
Atlanta we feel strongly that now is the
time to follow the rhetoric of concern
with the force of action the center is a
memorial research and educational
institution it is a people's Lobby for
sanctions against South Africa when we
had sanctions lifted them now for gun
control and amnesty for political
prisoners prisoners and we're working
for nuclear disarmament legislation to
protect voting rights to eliminate job
discrimination and to put people back to
work to name just a few of the issues of
continuing concern our staff and
volunteers have been involved in almost
every major social coalition of the last
quarter of a century we believe that
education in the values and virtues
needed to help create a more loving and
decent society must begin as early as
possible thus our early learning center
is pioneering curricula for preschool
age children that teaches them the power
of non-violent conflict resolution and
is teaching them how to love and to care
and to share and to give and teaching
them self-esteem it is so important that
we start at the earliest age possible so
our young people are six months through
four years and it makes a tremendous
difference when you see these young
people who have been exposed to love
they learn to love and we can teach
people to hate we certainly can teach
them to love and that's what we must do
[Applause]
it is time to demand that public schools
become partners and moral development
and we're not asking that they get
involved in religious controversy or
engaged in church and state conflict but
we must insist that they create programs
to teach young people about the values
that empowered Martin Luther King jr.
and these virtues are honestly tolerance
for diversity self respect and respect
for others love forgiveness compassion
sharing and most of all the moral
courage to resist peer group pressure
and to stand up for what is right
to help meet this challenge model
teaching project on dr. King's
nonviolent principles for the school's
grades kindergarten through 12 helps
teachers to integrate the principles of
non-violence and moral values taught by
Martin Luther King jr. into the
curriculum that already exists in the
public schools and it is being used by
schools across this nation the curricula
can help educate young people about the
values and responsibilities of democracy
we teach them about moral courage they
learn how to challenge violence without
doing injury to adversaries that piece
is the way and not just the goal they
learn about self discipline that is
needed to practice non-violence at the
personal and social level they learn how
to cope with interpersonal conflict in a
creative constructive way and this July
and the third week to be exact our
workshop on annual workshop on
non-violence which is a combination of a
youth workshop and adult workshop and
youth from the ages of 13 to 17 come
from across the country and I'm most
interested and I tend to focus on the
young people because they are the
leadership for tomorrow and it's so
important that we as I said get them at
the earliest stage possible but this
youth workshop very often has had many
at-risk young people and it from cities
like Detroit and Miami and st. Louis and
Philadelphia and New York and we see a
transformation in these young people
after four and a half days and we know
that is a transformation because they
give a testimony and some of the same
young people that come in who said dr.
King's nonviolent doesn't work anymore
it worked back then but it won't work
today mrs. King and I said well the
reason it hasn't worked is that it's
been understood when it's properly
understood and embraced it works so
these same young people will begin to
tell me how much they believe that
non-violence can work in their lives and
promised to use it to change the
conditions and most of all it gives them
a sense of hope and a sense of
empowerment you know the worst thing is
to feel that you can't do anything about
a problem and I know you have had that
experience and today there are so many
situations that that help you to feel
that way but one of the beauties of
non-violence is that it deals with you
first it helps you to have that sense of
I can do something about it and you
begin to look more critically at
yourself and in that process you begin
to like yourself better and even love
yourself and when you can when you can
love yourself properly you can begin to
love others as you should
we also have a scholars internship
program for college and graduate
students that many of you would probably
be interested in if you had a chance to
get away from your books for a while but
this is the practice theory and practice
of non-violence and I think it might be
it might be a good thing for some of you
and you probably would be interested if
you were able to do it we'd love to have
you come for a quarter or right now it's
a quarter we have done a quarter and a
semester but you have a chance to see
how the theory and the practice can be
meshed and and so many of our young
people have found new meaning for their
lives and have decided what they really
wanted to do with their lives in this
process I'm assuming that everybody here
knows what they want to do and that's
great keep on doing it if you found what
it is that you want to do with your life
but if you are having some struggles in
that regard feel free to contact us
we're also training law enforcement
personnel including police officers and
and for these Chiefs even as well as
correctional and administrative staff
and today too we have trained as almost
a thousand law enforcement personnel and
it makes for a better law enforcement
more humane law enforcement and it
minimizes the the crime and the violence
because so often for these well-meaning
police officers precipitate violence we
know this all too well during the
movement when so much of the violence
was precipitated by the way in which the
law enforcement personnel handled those
people who were breaking the law
deliberately there's a way to do it you
can do it with respect and that's really
what non-violence is all about
respecting each human being for what he
or she is recognizing that Martin Luther
King jr. had a global dream of peace and
Brotherhood the King Sunna extended its
training programs to other nations the
African National Congress and other
groups in South Africa has asked us to
come to direct
to a help to direct a non-violent
nonpartisan voter education training
program for the people of South Africa
and we've accepted this and so far we
have trained persons in South Africa who
working to train others so that they can
be ready and be comfortable and
confident about voting on April the 27th
when they vote for the new free South
free and democratic South Africa
and we have been invited to continue our
work because when a nation is going to
be led as all the predictions telling us
by people who have not even had an
opportunity to vote and has not been
involved in a political process like
like black South Africans and they are
in the majority and they have not had an
opportunity to understand and learn
about the process I'm sure they're going
to be just as there was in this nation
many conflicts and they are going to be
needing to be adept in the skills of
nonviolent conflict resolution and
reconciliation and they've asked us to
continue to work with them and I hope
that we will be able to do that of
course it takes money that means if we
get the funding to help with that we can
continue to do that but we're very
pleased about this because Martin and I
both have had a very strong interest in
in the liberation of South Africa for a
long long time and he often talked about
it from Montgomery on and to see that it
is is beginning to happen is a great
feeling of satisfaction not only in
South Africa but we've seen the progress
around the world that has been made
through nonviolent means looking at the
Soviet the former Soviet Union and
satellite nations that have have chosen
democratic ways of government over their
dictatorship without violence and
bloodshed those who did and we've seen
the fall of the Berlin Wall
all of this has happened and what seems
like a relatively short time and then
the signing of the accords with the
Palestinians and the Arab Israelis I
think this these are tremendous strides
that are being made and things are
beginning to happen in Haiti so lots of
progress is being made and the Haitian
people and their leadership as well that
invited us to come to Haiti to do
non-violence training
conciliation and we hope to be able to
do that we are preparing for that now so
we do feel that we are making progress
and that Martin Luther King Jr's message
is being felt and heard and embraced
around the world now it's not just his
message but his were universal he
embraced universal truths and all of the
great religions and of course Gandhi's
non-violence he was influenced by and as
well as as Thoreau and others but never
before had it been practiced on such a
wide scale as in the Western in the
southern part of the United State in the
Western Hemisphere and Martin Luther
King jr. showed that it could work in a
very materialistic society people say
well in India people are very spiritual
and it is a spiritual philosophy I mean
it is God centered and therefore it
won't work in America you know we
subscribe to
belief in God but we don't act that way
so as I want to finish up now because I
am afraid that I've talked much too long
I want to say that I believe that as a
nation we we must choose the alternative
of non-violence we've got a long way to
go but I think we're making progress
because I think it is the only way that
we can become the great nation that we
were supposed to be and Martin talked
about it in his dream I have a dream
speech and many of us believe that we
agree with that dream and we believe we
agree with Martin Luther King jr. but
this nation has a long way to go yet
before it fulfills Martin Luther King
Jr's dream of a true brotherhood
sisterhood a nation that cares for all
of its people
provides not on
the opportunities but enables people to
be better educated certainly well fed
and well housed and and and healthcare
able to have health care and culture for
their spirits we're not there yet there
are too many people who are hungry in
this country too many people who are
homeless
there's too much hatred there's too much
fear all of us are fearful when we walk
the streets at night if we live in a
city and maybe even in the country now
because we're afraid of being mugged or
robbed or killed this is not what
America was supposed to be and Martin
said we must have a revolution of values
and I believe that only a revolution of
values is going to change that condition
and therefore I challenge America I
challenge each one of us to work toward
that revolution of values so that we
begin to embrace those values that are
people centered today we have values
that are centered in materialistic gains
but we must be put people first and we
must make sure that our government does
that and our other institutions because
people it's people that really matters
and I have a vision for this nation a
vision that where every child will be
safe and secure from the deadly weapons
that we experience today and the scourge
of drugs and I see a nation that
nurtures his children and protects their
precious innocence with compassion and
caring and I see a nation where every
child is enrolled in a good school that
has all the resources needed to teach
them to love learning I see a nation
where people can get as much education
as their minds can absorb and a full
range of cultural opportunities to
enrich their spirits and I see a nation
where families are once again restored
to wholeness where parents can find
employment adequate to
living for their children I see a
beloved community where children need
look no further for positive role models
than the faces of their own mothers and
fathers we can create that Beloved
Community that Martin Luther King jr.
envisioned
let us now dare to embrace this common
vision and mobilize all of our resources
to bring it into being let us build a
society based on hope and let us not
only dream but create a new national
unity unburdened by the bigotry and
strengthened by conscience commitment to
prosperity through interracial brother
and sisterhood and I want to leave you
with some words from a sermon that my
husband preached the first Sunday in
February 1968 just two months prior to
his assassination and in this sermon he
called for a new commitment of sacrifice
and service from his followers and the
sermon was entitled to drum major
instinct and he said I and I think I
think it challenges us today animal in a
very relevant way it was relevant at the
time that he gave it but it's more
relevant today Martin said and there is
deep down within all of us an instinct
and it's kind of a drum major instinct a
desire to be out front a desire to lead
the parade a desire to be first and it's
something that runs the whole gamut of
life and the great issue of life is to
harness the drum major instinct and he
went on to say that if you want to be
important wonderful if you want to be
great wonderful but recognize that he
who is greatest among you shall be your
servant
that's your new definition of greatness
he said it means that everybody can be
great because everybody can serve you
don't have to know about Plato and
Aristotle to serve you don't have to
know the second
thermodynamics and physics to serve you
only need our heart full of grace on a
soul generated by love and you can be
that servant Martin Luther King Jr's
word words provide an urgent challenge
to all of us to become peacemakers and I
hope you will become drum major in those
areas of lasting value Pia drum major
for human rights be a drum major for
love be a drum major for justice be a
drum major for peace be a drum major for
the Beloved Community with all of your
heart and soul and you can be that
servant thank you and god bless you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you much mrs. King for those very
historic and educational words we must
now excuse mrs. King because she has a
flight to catch
very soon she's been promised to get out
of Boston by 2:30 and so if you would
just give us a moment to excuse her and
we'll get her on her way
mrs. King before you leave I'd like to
say a few words my name is Charisse
Guillory I'm a junior at Harvard
University and the best list of the
lambda Upsilon chapter of Alpha Kappa
Alpha Sorority Incorporated Alpha Kappa
Alpha is a sisterhood comprised of
130,000 dynamic women and today it is my
distinct honor to present a small token
to one of these women most gracious lady
Coretta Scott King you stand out as a
light even among the brilliance that is
Alpha Kappa Alpha your commitment to
civil rights legislation commitment to
excellence in education and dedicated
service to all mankind are the epitome
of what I and all of Alpha Kappa Alpha
strive to achieve the lambda epsilon
chapter welcomes you to MIT and I'm so
proud to call you muscle
[Music]
you